I've become obsessed with this and I I
have found myself studying the hell out
of 1790 France and early 20 Century
Russia because the this same thing
happens every once in a while in history
where people become hysterical and it's
what I think is one of the main
liabilities for the mob hysteria and MOB
action and the aggression is the emotion
of Envy Envy is alive and well right now
and envy is different than jealousy
jealousy is you know you know somebody
has something I wish I had it makes me
feel uncomfortable and I go man I don't
like that but I'll work hard to get it
Envy is he's got something he's got a
car I like I makes me pisses me off I
have to destroy him that's what Envy is
Envy is I have to destroy the other
person and if you're in a mob mobs love
to gather and focus aggression on one
person or one group and scapegoat them
and scape hey you're speaking to the
choir because you know I'm a Jew and we
have been persecuted from our existence
and you know supposedly we're the ones
with all the money and we're the ones
that control everything there's the Envy
yeah but we're not even 2% of the
population we don't really run
everything I do fine but I would imagine
most billionaires are not Jews you know
and most people that run countries and
are are not Jews but for some reason
there has been a f focus
on us and the scariness that you're
pointing out has is it's it's some weird
his St it feels like it all started with
like Trump and then it went to co and
then it went to Palestine and it's the
it feels kind of the same but it's all
ripped this SC this dressing off a wound
or something so we can look at it I
didn't even know this stuff was there I
really didn't understand how bad these
festering emotions were and yet they're
RIT large right now I'm wondering ing if
uh social media is a salt oh for Rocket
Fuel I wanted to ask you because you
recently I think it was yesterday or the
day before you posted something about
free speech on platforms on social media
platforms I assume that it's regarding
Elon musk's response and then he he lost
a bunch of AD dollars right so I wanted
to ask how you felt about
that uh glorious yeah sorry but but I
thought oh somebody's pushing back cuz
because this is I don't know about you
guys but I've been attacked it's NE what
you get attacked for is never what you
say it's always what somebody says you
said or some manufactured aspect of
something you said it's really never a
representation of what you said or did
in my experience ever and so I knew that
whatever happened
there he it for sure wasn't what really
happened the way they reported it have
you ever heard of Gelman Amnesia no you
know what that is no Gman Ames I know
Michael Gelman but I still remember him
this this is Gman Amia is a term that
was coined to describe a certain uh
phenomenon Gelman was a famous physicist
and he noticed that whenever he'd read
an a a journalistic report about physics
it just was way off it never got it
right but then he'd go re continue
reading about complex politics and world
events and assume that was all right and
of course that's as off as anything else
and if you whenever anybody writes an
article about you particular an attack
article you realize how distorted the
Press is it makes you it really brings
it home for you but not only how
distorted what social media has done
each of us each of us live in a no
matter how open we are we live in this
bubble of reality that isn't like
anybody else's reality that's and that's
terrible right because uh I think
systematically um the algorithm you know
I mean the the system yeah is such that
when you click on something and you have
interest in in a headline you you are
virtually you know changing your you're
creating your algorithm
yeah